hey here we are once again yep people I
wonder people again we got a new movie
review we got Davis pretty good movie I
liked it I liked it very much as well I
think I mentioned this on the sidetrack
show yesterday but this actually
premiered on lose my train of thought
because I I think I mentioned this on
yet a track show that I actually first
started watching this movie because I
guess it premiered on shudder on June
18th and they premiered it on joe bob's
drive-in and i first started watching it
but i think it was like a Saturday night
and I was like you know I drank a lot
and I was like really sleepy so I think
I fell asleep like partly and I didn't
like remember a lot of it so I
definitely wanted to you know revisit it
cuz it seemed really cool and it seemed
to need like a a more sober watch and
I'm glad I did because this movie was
read this was another horror comedy it's
called scare package it's actually an
anthology now from what I could
determine I think it pret
the nightmares Film Festival of 2019
where it was voted you know the
audience's or whoever the critics or
everything voted it the best horror
comedy at the festival and it's pretty
easy to see why I mean I love horror
anthology movies anyway but this was a
really good one and this is one of the
few actually it's kind of the only one I
can think of offhand
where the wraparound is like really kind
of like the best part of the movie I
mean it's all good like all the segments
are good you know some of them are
better than others that always happens
but this one even the wraparound story
is excellent what makes this one good is
that it's Jen it's retro they're taking
it back to the 80s they even got damn
lines where the [ __ ] VCR is [ __ ]
up music everything that the content the
special effects was a lot of
core in it as funny it's retro Gore and
not even a single pretense a any kind of
political message which is making a
political message in itself nowadays
because they're always trying to insert
something it's just the movie just
doesn't give it doesn't give a [ __ ] it's
a good movie it's super fun and it's
interesting because what they did and
this was a pretty clever um you know
kind of framing by device to I guess
nightmare cinema kind of did a similar
but I think this worked out better
because it made more sense in the
context so you got your wrap around
story which is based around a video
store now this it seems to be set in the
present day because of the TVs and the
cell phones and everything like that but
the video store at the at the heart of
it in the framing device is kind of like
a throwback like a retro yeah ova this
DVD it's hard to tell yeah it's hard to
tell is it just kind of threw it
together it doesn't read okay yeah so
it's called rad sheds and even like the
and I'll I'll kind of get into this a
little bit too but even the the logo of
rad chad's looks almost exactly like the
joe bob's drive-in logo and the guy rad
chad who owns it is like a huge Joe Bob
Briggs fan so what the kind of setup is
is that there's this weird creepy dude
that hangs around who's like a total
like horror dork
and he wants to work at the store but
rad Chad does not want him to work in
the store cuz he's kind of weird and
creepy and annoying so he hires this
other guy this other kid whose name is
han and so it was like four foot five
yeah he was like a little a little short
guy yeah and so and so there's like
conflict between the creepy guy who's I
think his name is Sam and hawin because
you know Han really wants to do a good
job and but Sam doesn't think he knows
enough about horror movies or whatever
so there's a training thing and then it
seems like the you know the individual
like stories that they're showing in
within the anthology are like on the
videotapes likes because he's showing
videotapes like hey check out this movie
or like you know they're playing them in
the store and
like that so that's kind of like how the
framing device goes and then as the
movie goes on you get to the end part
and then the framing device opens up and
becomes its own story as well
which I thought was kind of a cool and
like I said that's probably I think it's
probably my favorite one the framing
device story particularly like when it
goes into the end you know what I mean
I've got to see it again yeah yeah I
want to see it again to do a different
analysis of it but yeah there's a good
movie it's fun yeah it's and I was
getting distracted a lot when I was
watching it but I love the tone this
movie I mean it was hilarious like some
of the gore gags and this this was
definitely made I mean it's like seven
different directors one of the segments
fun fact um was directed by Baron von
the comedian who he's been on tons of
[ __ ] but I know him because he played
servo on the reboot of Mystery Science
Theater like when they did it on Netflix
so he's actually he directed the one
segment he's kind of in it just like as
you know like in a cameo kind of a
parents so what you got is this is
basically you know seven different
directors or however many it is and you
can tell that everybody is like loves
[ __ ] horror movies and there's like
some deep cuts in this like some of the
references they make and some of because
what it is it's kind of like it's very
meta and it's like making fun of the
tropes of horror but also like in a
really affectionate it kind of had a
little bit I don't want to say that was
like scream because it wasn't like that
it we had more of like a cabin in the
woods type of vibe to it maybe where it
was just kind of like meta you know work
in some of the things like the
characters were aware that they were in
a horror movie and we're trying to do
things to like get them out of the
horror movie you know what I mean yeah
they're just having fun with it yeah and
like you know the the very first part of
it like before you even get to the
framing device of Brad chad's there's a
there's a segment called cold-open
which is basically about this guy whose
name is Mike Myers and he's like this
just this really nice guy but he's tired
of only being in horror movies and being
in the cold open you know what I mean so
they showed him like
doing things like moving the sign so
like the the camping teenagers go to the
abandoned insane asylum and like selling
a house like a haunted house to somebody
and like doing all this other kind of
stuff and he wants to like survive to
the end of the movie or like be the
killer or like you know be a bigger part
of it so it kind of goes like that but
it's like I said it's very very meta so
then like I said it goes into like the
framing device of the of the horror
Emporium and then after that I think is
probably it seemed like of all the
reviews that I watched and read of this
movie this seems to be like the
all-around favorite which was one time
in the woods it's a very simple setup
where it's just kind of like making fun
of like the campers out in the woods
trope but basically you have all these
people out there this guy comes up to
them and says you know you need to kill
me or you need to stop me and then he
just starts turning into this goo
monster yeah and I'm laughing just
thinking about it it's like the gore in
this it's it's like it's super
disgusting it's super hilarious and they
know that you've watched a bunch of
horror movies and then know how you
think so the characters are actually
messing with it with messing with you
about what you're thinking like you said
some it's meta yeah you know not all the
time but most of the time because they
know that you know what's gonna happen
next or they know you know the trope the
trope so they're gonna [ __ ] with you
about it I liked it I did to you and
like I said it's it's easy um you know
the tone of it is kind of hard to pull
off so it's like you don't you want to
be making fun of it but you also you can
tell that these people that made this
are also like really really loved horror
movies yeah and so they're not making
fun of it and then kind of like
mean-spirited way it's also pretty high
quality it's a high quality movie we're
not talking about philosophy
I mean philosophy it had good parts
about it but that's a cheap movie this
actually looks a lot more expensive yeah
I did I'd be curious to know how much
this cost to make I mean I heard it was
like a video or something yeah I heard
it was low-budget and like you know
since it just went around to festivals
and things like that but it shows you
what you can do on a low budget though
yeah it really does it really didn't
occur to me that it was like a little
budget movie it looked expensive
particularly a lot of effects
you know in in that one segment like
with the guy melting and like turning
into goo and then there's like you know
people getting hit in the crotch with
axes and people exploding well this is
this is an independent film it's not a
big [ __ ] Hollywood studio and I'm
sure that if you look at the budget some
of those Hollywood movies you know it's
all padded out there's a lot of
corruption going on in there it can't
cost that much yeah in dollar movies
there's just you know if you're in a
more efficient system you know you can
get a lot more for your buck than what a
big Hollywood studio [ __ ] gets for
their dollar think about it well yeah
this movie's this one we looked at I
thought it's cooler than say like
Invisible Man
and even though Invisible Man was a good
movie I really liked it but I bet you
Invisible Man was [ __ ] four times
five times what this cost although even
that was like a fairly inexpensive ROI
yes that was my examples oh yeah that's
my example just thought about the
efficiency of these new independent
films yeah you know you can just get a
lot of bang for your buck is like
there's still a lot of old-school talent
out there well yeah and like I said I
think after CGI proliferated so much in
the 90s and early 2000s especially in
horror and sci-fi I think that was kind
of like a big backlash against you know
using too much CGI because it just got
overused because you could use it so
people used it too much yeah and then I
think people got sick of it cuz it was
ubiquitous and I think there was kind of
like a movement and a little bit to go
back toward doing things practically or
in camera and bad CG looks like [ __ ] and
it still does that's the thing and we've
mentioned this like hundreds of times
before probably but it's like good
practical effects will never age because
it's there it's you know the technology
is not gonna like age out of it even bad
practical effects are better than bad CG
yeah about it well yeah it's like I said
basically they're right yeah and the
people are acting reacting to it yeah
but no [ __ ] there's a lot of shitty
practical effects movies horror movies
that they're still awesome
well yeah I'm just like cuz I well I'm a
lot more willing to give leeway to yeah
bad practical because at least somebody
made that with their hands like
Cronenberg movies yeah I mean a lot of
special effects and there weren't that
sophisticated but it holds up look at
the brood yeah the brig didn't have
expensive special effects they weren't
even great special effects does a
[ __ ] great movie yeah well and I
think the same thing applies here
although like I said you know
particularly the segment with the goo
monster which was probably the goriest
although they were all pretty gory body
though that it but yeah and it was just
like it was just one of those things
that was so gory and over-the-top that
you couldn't like elephant laughs even
though it's completely disgusting
because the whole time the dudes turning
into the goo monster he's just kind of
like making like commentary but although
you know that that's that special those
special effects right there we're almost
probably almost on par with a lot of
what you would see in the thing yeah the
difference was is that it was the
lighting it was in broad daylight
yeah so kind of showed some you know a
lot of its flaws had it been in a darker
you know set or a darker environment it
would have looked even better but the
tone of the movies [ __ ] it man just you
know just do it well they're just having
fun
definitely this movie is a lot of fun
yes yeah I mean you know the goo
monsters telling jokes [ __ ] it yeah he's
just you know like oh man I think my
eyes are gonna fall out yeah you don't
have to be convicted that's really a
melting man as they be entertained but
he's like you know some of my goo is
like over there and I'm kind of like can
you kind of scrape it back over here
because I'm afraid that when I go back
like I don't know yeah so so that was
like easily probably the funniest and
glorious kind of one and then there was
one called mr. which was kind of about
one of those like weird men going their
own way groups and stuff like that and
then this one guy like and it kind of
doesn't go in the direction that you
think it's gonna go and you think it's
gonna go in a Fight Club kind of
direction and it doesn't and then
there's one called girls night out of
the body which is about three girls that
are gonna thing and they steal like a
skull shaped lollipop and bad things
happen after that then there's kind of
another you know kind of slasher trope
one it's called the night he came back
again part for the final kill which is
kind of making fun of your supernatural
slashers that like you know that they
won't die so basically what the setup is
is there's a fourth of July
I killer and the you know that all the
people in the movie have captured him
and her doing like just increasingly
crazy things like to get him to die for
real and then like all of them are like
dying in crazy accidental ways and [ __ ]
like that like I said people explode
people are filled with fireworks it's
delightful and then there's one called
so much to do which is the one that was
directed by Baron Vaughn from Mystery
Science Theater and that kind of has to
do with that was a little bit one of the
weaker ones I think it was still good
but it wasn't quite as funny as yeah the
ones did have like some funny moments it
was kind of about this guy it didn't
really explain a lot but there was a guy
that got taken over by two wizards
necromancer's something like that and
then like he possessed this woman and
then it had to do with this show called
battle of mages and she was like really
adamant that she didn't want spoilers
and she was like kind of beating up this
demon that had taken over her body or
something like that it was pretty fun
like it was very simple and it was like
kind of funny and then you get like the
last segment which is kind of a
continuation of RAD Chad's horror thing
because that's like all the same
characters but this one's called horror
hypothesis so you get Chad and Han and
Sam and then you have all these other
characters and then it goes very meta
and very cabin in the woods where it's
like this research facility that seems
to be like trying to figure out like all
these hopes like tropes of horror movies
like why does the girl keep falling down
like when she's running in the slasher
stand and everything like that now I
will say that even though the de gory
one like in the woods one that made me
laugh a lot the thing that made me laugh
the most and I'm not gonna spoil it
completely but it was at the end of this
bit when the one guy was like trying to
approach the killer or trying to kill
like the slasher or whatever and they
totally did an homage to Friday the 13th
the final chapter with the with Corey
Feldman and everything and it was
hilarious I just laughed and laughed and
laughed now it's like if you didn't if
you've never seen Friday the 13th part 4
that would just that would probably
wouldn't be that funny to you but I
I guess it would still be funny but it's
much funnier if you've seen that movie
and because everything and it's cool
because I feel like when they made this
movie they didn't really they made this
for horror fans yeah I mean other people
can enjoy it it's still funny it's still
gory it's you know if you've been around
for a long time you'll understand it a
lot but if you're into like you know old
horror movies like 80s horror movies
then you will get a lot more enjoyment
out of the 70s you would yeah there are
tons of like references back and there
is also a very funny cameo appearance by
the aforementioned Joe Bob Briggs who
was in the last part of this which I
guess is why because this is what was
funny when I started watching it on joe
bob's drive-in it was like on his live
show that he does on shudder like i'm
fright I think it's on Friday nights and
um you know the Darcie the male girl she
said to him she's like oh you're in this
and so and I didn't I fell asleep before
it ended so I didn't realize like I
thought she just meant oh you're in this
because Brad Chad had like a picture of
him like hanging from his you know rear
view mirror and like he wore the bolo
tie and everything and he was a big fan
but no he is Jim Briggs it is actually
in this he has like a cameo but it's not
like until the really end and he's
playing like himself and you get like
Brad Chad is like you know all found
fangirling and [ __ ] like that squealing
about it he's like trying to save him
from the killer and all this other kind
of crap but it's like this was just I
really want this to get like a wider
audience because this was just a super
fun super gory and especially if you
like anthologies especially like 80s
movies this was just a delightful
delightful movie and like a hell of a
lot of fun to watch I mean we've really
seen like a lot of decent horror flicks
lately haven't we yeah and I was was
watching another review of this because
apparently this also played at the
Chattanooga Film Festival and one of the
reviewers that I watch had paid because
Chattanooga Film Festival this year it's
completely online so he's like I just
paid 30 bucks and I got to see every
single horror movie that they showed and
he's like almost all of them were
excellent so he's like so that's really
cool that like I paid 30 bucks and I got
to see like all of these movies which I
probably wouldn't have got to see had I
gone to the film festival like I'm
Jefferson Matt no mango badger he just
mentioned it too he said you know like
these smaller budget movies are gonna be
that's the wave of the future I believe
so too yeah I mean some of these smaller
budget independent films that we've seen
on streaming services on on Xbox
I thought they thought in general I had
more fun watching those than the ones we
were watching on AMC uh a list back when
that was running I mean they had some
good tentpole movies that last year they
had a few here and there but just
numerically I think I like you know
what's been going on streaming better
well yeah like I said you know and we
talked about this a lot it's just it's
it's so much easier for like a small
group of people who you don't need a ton
of money you don't need you know all you
need is like just to know how you put
the [ __ ] together and then if you can
get into a festival or something like
that I mean you can get it seen by
millions of people because you can just
get a streaming platform I mean like I
said I don't know how much this movie
cost to make but they premiered it at a
film festival and then shutter picked it
up and now it's on shutter and like all
these people can see it and all these
people have reviewed it the only thing
that stood out over the past couple
years AMC was like the John wick movies
I really enjoyed um that the the riff
track live shows that they had then the
retro movies where they did alien one
you know that was that was really good
what was the other retro movie that we
saw it was good
The Shining The Shining yeah um but a
lot of the movies that we've been seeing
streaming that we really enjoyed they
never they wouldn't have shown that name
see yeah a lot of them wouldn't have
gotten theatrically or never would ago
you know but like I said you know that's
kind of one of the cool things about
streaming yes I like to leave the house
yes I like to go see those on the big
screen and stuff but you get a lot more
options and you get a lot more I mean
you know just like the guy was saying
about the film festival he's like it's
really cool that the film festival even
though it sucks the reason why it had to
go online but he's like you know I could
watch all the movies for $30
whereas if I had gone to it in person
you know cuz of the scheduling and you
know [ __ ] like that I might have missed
some of them and he's like so I got to
see pretty much all of the horror movies
that they had and they were all pretty
good so he's like I got to see a bunch
of [ __ ] that I wouldn't have got to say
not this from AMC said they were gonna
open back up but then I started hearing
no they're gonna they're gonna open back
up and a limited yeah I think some of
them are gonna I think they're closing
the ones that were under performing like
perform but what about ours happened I
don't know I haven't heard anything
about the local one I mean I feel like
that one that was a nice one well that's
a nice one and also that mall it's
attached to the mall and that is not a
dead mall by any stretch of the
imagination I die though but it might
now but even like I know cuz a lot of
malls are struggling well that we're
struggling before that that one was not
yeah it was only running on two eight
two anchor stores and one of them was a
Sears with it as years yeah was it no no
the Sears was already gone
no Sears left already go but I noticed
that there weren't a lot of vacancies
that like in with the smaller stores
they still had like a bunch of other
yeah but I was looking I was looking
into I was looking into the details of
mall ology most of the damn income came
from the anchor stores oh yeah that's
the casein the little stores that were
in the middle really the rents that they
were paying we're actually pretty you
know I mean we're pretty low like you
there it's not enough to run the damn
mall
yeah upkeep of the mall well yeah it's
always your anchor it's the anchors and
that that mall even though it looked
great two of the anchors were already
gone and it was running on a surviving
two and I think one of them was to
Macy's or something they were all in
danger
Dillard's Dillard's I think it was
Dillard's they were all in Davis a
little in they're all in danger of
closing
oh yeah and wide level so I was just
saying that I mean compared to some of
the like dead malls that we sit on like
you know South channel or damn bells
channel this show where there's like
nobody it's like usually when we went
there because sometimes we'd go to the
food court or FYE or something before
the movie and the place was usually
crowded yeah and most of the and I think
almost all the storefronts were full
there I think there's some like I think
there's some you know kind of low and
middle income housing right there in
that
area and that was that was bringing them
in there yeah there's a lot of
apartments there's a lot of offices
around there as well where people
problem is problem is is that the
anchors in other stores fail yes so the
so the anchor closes on a nationwide
level yeah
doesn't anything do it that model and
then once all the anchors nationwide are
gone the mall cannot generate enough
money all the little renters to keep the
upkeep of the mall yeah and it slowly
just starts to consume itself it's it's
that's an antique way of doing retail
the the future of a pretty much retail
is gonna be online most of it or in the
uncovered open malls so it's going back
to a Main Street style yeah because the
enclosed mall with all the
air-conditioning and then hooked up to
the damn bus network you know kids get
in there and [ __ ] it up and then the
adults that spend money don't want to go
in there anymore and that's basically
what all the analysts say teenagers kill
malls yeah and that's the problem well
nothing I mean even back in the day when
it's like you know that was kind of the
thing it's teenagers would go hang out
in the mall but it's like they didn't
have a lot of disposable income back in
the 80s and 90s yeah they would just
kind of hang out in there and they
weren't selling drugs or shooting people
well and that's that was the end of it
yeah because it's been going on for
twenty or thirty years just the slow and
as soon as the online option came it
started to fall apart
this seems to be that what they're going
to a Main Street model you know like
around there where where five guys is
and the next to it [ __ ] the ice cream
put like that well yeah that's what they
want because there's no air conditioning
you go in a store and to go in the store
you got to buy something yeah it's a
racket everything's a racket it's all
about manipulating masses to get money
out of them well yeah yeah that's how
you make money but I mean the thing is
it's not I don't know it's it is a
racket but it's like we're not you're
not gonna go in five guys unless you
want a [ __ ] burger that's a no
they're not making you come it's a
racket it's dividing minutes a rack in
terms of imitation they're dividing
paying customers from non paying
customer yeah and and you have to come
in the walls
encouraged non-paying
because it encourages you to like you to
hang out in the damn air-conditioning
and you unemployed teenagers in there
doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] and the adults say
I don't want to be in here yeah that man
took and that's evidently what was going
on somebody somebody asked if we had
been to Key West and if we'd seen Robert
the doll you know what's weird it's like
I have lived in Florida pretty much my
whole entire life I was born here I have
never been to Key West I should probably
go I think the farthest south I've been
is Miami I have been to Miami a couple
times but I've never been to Key West
I'd also kind of like to go to the
Everglades one of these days it's weird
how many places in Florida even though
I've liked lived here my whole entire
life but uh yeah so uh any other
questions that we have to answer you're
scrolling through there and you see
everything else in danger exact I was
just talking about malls trying to jump
in a conversation late ass first and ask
me what's his blood what does about know
we were just talking about malls and
that malls or malls are going to die off
because on a nationwide level the anchor
stores aren't doing well and the malls
can't survive without anchor stores they
were paying most of the bills yeah I
mean you have to think that the whole
thing about department stores yeah
that's a very I mean department stores
that kind of whole concept that's very
like [ __ ] late 19th early 20th
century yeah it was like a one-stop shop
for everything which you don't really
need that anymore so I feel like shits
gonna go either like online behemoth
it's like Amazon where you can just buy
everything and not have to leave your
house or it's gonna be like small
specialty shops like boutiques where you
go to get a specific thing because if
you looked at a damn department store
what it was it was a gigantic store that
had a little bit of everything but but
if you looked at a single item it was
always some [ __ ] you didn't want it was
almost kind of like a Soviet sales pitch
where here take this we have four purses
you can have one of these we had you
know it was like you have a selection of
for yeah it was not kind of for purses
and then we have [ __ ] five couches
and then we have
two different kinds of [ __ ] pants
suits you know it's just they had
everything but only a couple choices of
each one well yeah because they only
have so much room so I mean the same
thing happens with Walmart I only have
so much [ __ ] space to put [ __ ] in
right so it's like they only have like
so small like number I remember growing
up in 80's and everybody had to send
same damn furniture and the same damn
clothes over and over and over again it
was like something out of like a Soviet
Union well that's what kind of cracks me
up whenever I see movies from back then
or movies that are like nowadays that
are like you know kind of retro for that
time period and when you saw the like
when I was watching stranger things and
everything like that I was just like
holy crap we had that couch oh my god we
had those dishes oh my god because
everybody had liked it there weren't
that many divorces well that's this one
time well that's capitalism I said no
not really
war a lot more that was more like
communism capitalism was you know small
family businesses with homemade [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] made on premises you know just
huge corporations I can sound out booked
one-size-fits-all [ __ ] designs it was
like just like something out of Soviet
Union well that's what I'm a it's like
so like it's so much easier now it is to
get like exactly what you want it's like
you know you don't have to just go to
like really like service merchandise or
something like that and pick one of the
like for couch design thing and we were
growing up if you want to cool clothes
you had good like a second-hand store
and try to find something it came out of
the 1920s or 30s or 40s and then modify
it into something to look gothic rock
rock you had to do a lot of custom [ __ ]
because you couldn't buy any of those
clothes not really and even if he even
if you could like you could buy in
Spencer like I had I saved up for a
really long time this was like back in
the late 80s maybe because I really
really wanted like a real still bone
course it's like they're so easy to get
nowadays yeah not back in the day back
then I had a little one yeah they were
like it was almost $400 like I had to
order like a woman that made it for me
yeah like you know custom but I mean I
saved up for like a year or so you like
to buy that yeah it was super expensive
so it wasn't capitalism as you know it
it was like a lot more like [ __ ]
Soviet Communism Africa and there was no
choice
everything was just standardized
standardized mass production [ __ ]
commodity commodity clothing well yeah
like I said everybody no more couches
that's why it's like so much easier
nowadays to find like you know if I can
look and be like you know I'd really
like a wash cloth that has Cthulhu on it
guys and it's like you can find that
like immediately it's like you don't
even have to or it's easy to make it
yourself you know all you have to do is
flick do you would design yourself and
upload it to [ __ ] to something and
they'll print it and send you one you
know what I mean so but anyway we went
off on the team we might do I'm not sure
I'm we might do another one tomorrow
because tomorrow's Tuesday and that's
when the regular episodes go up but I
already politicize it so we might do a
sidetracks tomorrow we'll see how it was
maybe we'll talk about [ __ ] you know
news and current events or whatever or
just whatever you guys won't talk about
yeah well just like I said we'll
probably just do that tomorrow probably
around 2 o'clock like usual because like
I said this is it everybody likes me
make predictions though they want me to
go Sir Thomas on them you know I might
be able to channel some [ __ ] especially
if I've been drinking we maybe we ought
to do it when it's late later on in the
evening you want to do an evening one
see me right probably probably get more
people we can drink it to an afternoon
but I'd feel like it's like not drink
not like our job we're just four to go
job working we're going back to like
madman day yeah yeah every one of those
[ __ ] offices executive offices had a
bar in it I know thinking about drinking
ties his work at one place that had well
it was a liquor distribution company
yeah and go vodka they did actually have
a bar you weren't allowed to just like
belly up to it and drink whenever you
wanted to but you sometimes on Friday is
like an hour before like they would be
like oh we got a new flavor we got a guy
to mix a new cocktail and they'd have
everybody like in there and you could
have some but yeah because they don't
want anybody like puking and barfing and
later the [ __ ] it's just like but I just
thought that was when I first started
working there that was one of the first
things I did was take it sure that like
and we're gonna place with a big ass
yeah I like that job actually it was fun
but yeah so if you have shudder and you
like horror anthologies you like 80s
movies you like super gory horror
comedies then this is a really good one
and you really need to check it out more
people need to see it because it's
really really kick-ass Joe Bob Briggs
also did a version on his channel if you
want to check out that he's always
amusing but that'll do it for today's
matinee we will probably see you guys
again tomorrow